okay we are back
live
um and I where are these Bots get out of
messages I get a your Discord thing I
saw a message somewhere oh there it is
M was
4% I One update epoch
ha
330k very
nice I'll fix this [ __ ] for him that's
no big deal it's
let me go check this one other thing and
uh then we'll get back to
right cool we are good all cut up on
messages believe
good
okay let's look at our experiments first
this seems like it actually kind of did
something
um
oops this seems like it actually kind of
did something which I'm
surprised cuz I thought that this was
really stupid
um Okay so
so see so this is the one from
before this goes up
to 28 2900 so this doesn't quite get
there um and it gets up to like here on
the total time
steps and then if we look at this
one
interesting so this is still a very
clean set of
Curves um and actually the time steps
are nice too it's got these like two
Divergent paths which is a little
weird but it's not it's not doing as
well
overall let's see
why this is like a very
tight this is very interesting
um I didn't expect this out the
gate this is almost tighter than the
other one and this is
like this is more the shape that we want
as well where it's like a very quick
Ascent on total time
steps this does this this continuity is
a little weird but you know
whatever um
so batch size is correct mini batches
doesn't go to eight okay this gets stuck
which is
weird learning rate is way
off is very weird gamma's
correct uh Lambda is
correct update epox correct BPT Horizon
is
correct uh n Maps get stuck as well that
should be higher then cost is scaled
nicely whoa oh what the
heck double parito
front very
clean but then this doesn't make
sense you
see this is like beautifully clean and
then this one this portion is fine but
then what is this
right so it's got to be a quirk of the
function
now I didn't think it was a great
function but I don't know why it does
this
specifically
um let me
see so this is what we did and I added a
bias to this Improvement term as well
the
bias the bias should just make it non-
negative it's a big bias but that
shouldn't
matter so I did Improvement Plus let me
make sure this is right
yeah so here's the Improvement Plus 100
this is
conservative Improvement and then we
have conservative
absolute and then the thing that I
changed here other than this bias was
that I added or I divided by the cost
estimate so how does this
how does this
work not this one where'd it
go so I divided by the cost estimate
so this is 12338 down
here this is a low cost
suggested this is bizarre I sure I don't
have like multiple
336 you know these are from the
same the same runs
right this
three four yeah and here it's like
42 this is very very weird
[Music]
it's not sampling points on the
genuinely welcome YouTube folks this is
Redevelopment of a hyperparameter tuning
algorithm and we're we've got something
that's really good on the synthetic test
but it's just there are a couple last
things that I'm not satisfied with yet
and uh one of them is the way that it
scales to a longer and longer
experiments over time
me do this first just to make sure that
I'm not totally
let me think in the meantime if I can
figure out what this
does oh
also not cover the
acquisition
value so Improvement gives
you uniform
sampling across the Paro
front right and it's just wherever you
can improve the Paro
front
now this is annoying because if you have
a perfect estimate of the Paro front
uh it doesn't mean you can't sample but
it gives it turns into uniform
sampling right so if you have a perfect
estimate of the Paro front you uniformly
sample around existing parito
points you don't bias towards longer
experiments so the goal
is as you get more
confident which generally means that
there are fewer places where you improve
an expectation that's fine okay so it's
it's off of the parito curve fit
really all the sampling is done off the
Pito curve fit it's not done off of your
existing experiments
so let's say that you learn a good curve
bit off of the quicker
runs
okay then
what so Improvement
[Music]
becomes let's say a
uniform it goes to zero really but we're
going to add a bias to that so let's say
it's just
uniform okay so now you want to
bias towards higher
cost no you don't want to bias towards
higher cost you want to bias towards
higher performance which can be higher
cost so absolute performance term does
that already without doing the divide by
cost I remember not liking that for some
reason
like if you have uncertainty across the
whole
front then this can bias you towards
high
cost the thing that you're trying to
express here right is you want to move
towards higher performance as you become
certain you want to move away from high
cost as you're
uncertain well wait you always want to
go towards higher
performance and away from high cost
unless you're certain
either your base acquisition
function it's Improvement times absolute
good and then there should be a cost
penalty
confidence is that
good so model uncertainty we have that's
just just the variance in the cost
prediction
I don't think this cost penalty term is
well
formulated does this even make sense
what this is trying to do
I mean you're probably pretty damn
accurate on the cost of stuff it's
really easy to predict that
does this bias really screw screwing up
the
algorithm that'd be
weird
right 50 this looks like it could be or
52 uh
right yeah look at
that even this one is
better then that we didn't even look at
this one
better that's weird that that bias term
would mess stuff
up I'll let it run a little longer just
to be sure but
um and time steps are interesting
here well this is I mean this is bad
this is uh too early to do this didn't
explore bat didn't explore anything
yeah so that's kind of weird
this is definitely bad okay well what if
I get rid of this bias
because let's just try this empirically
I have no idea if this should do
anything I don't honestly think it
should
uh cost no
bias I honestly don't think that they
should do anything but we'll try it
I think you're still going to get the
weird
split I mean here's the other thing I
can do
right I can just look
at this is the weird
one this
one so this is the best run that I have
it gets batch mini batch the only thing
it screws up for whatever weird reason
is it doesn't get the learning rate it
gets gamma nicely it gets Lambda
nicely it's update Epoch
Horizon this gets
everything the only two issues with this
so for whatever reason it doesn't get
learning rate but a lot of them have
that
problem and then the total time steps
doesn't go up fast
enough this should really go up way
faster because
like this Improvement is all just from
time
step I mean that's a very simple
experiment to
run to just like double the time
step
I mean something still feels wrong to me
about this
like all I do is absolute performance
times
cost I me absolute performance this is
All I
Do by what mechanism does this control
cost there's literally no penalty for
sampling longer and longer
runs like early
how do you get 4,000 m's on a
CPU these are all written in C they run
a m like they run a million steps per
second on One Core minimum so you
literally just run them serially in a
loop on One Core that's
it nothing
magic so of them are a little heavier so
we multiprocess them maybe we use two
cores for some of them a couple of them
a few more than that but
yeah they're just really really
fast they're not that hard to write
either we've got all sorts of brand new
RL people contributing these like I
wrote nurl Mo MOA and uh snake the rest
of them are contributed by our users
I code review all of them and I edit
them and stuff but the main
implementation is by
contributors I'm still not happy with
the way that this algorithm interacts
with with
cost I think under this formulation
just
this so what is num M's referring to in
your sweep on GPU it's typically
referred to the number of M's running
yes literally that so we are
running it doesn't necess they don't
have to run in parallel though like you
get a batch of 4,000
observations but they're run in serial
it's just that they run so fast that you
don't notice
like our training will have 0% Z to 1%
of the time spent running the
environment it's actually better than
the GPU environments a lot of them
because they waste time running they
waste GPU time running the
environment a lot of the GPU
implementations are actually slower than
our CPU
implementations which makes sense
like gpus are not designed to run
arbitrary logic they're not CPUs are
designed to run arbitrary logic like the
only reason that people have gone crazy
over GPU environments outside of like
High Fidelity physics is because like
researchers really want to write Python
and uh it turns out if you just write
stuff in C it's
faster I'm being a little bit faes here
like we did some additional optimization
there's some fancy shared memory stuff
um but if you look at the code it's
really easy to write these things like
the CPU environment code is dramatically
simpler than GPU environment code like
compare puffer environments to like
Jack's environments it is so much less
painful to write our our CPU environment
and they're faster
this I'm pretty sure what's happening
here as lame as this is I'm pretty sure
what's
happening is just total time step starts
out
low and it just takes a while uh because
the standard deviation of the search
space for this parameter so low it just
takes a while to increase
it so like essentially it's just you
have until the algorithm bumps this
parameter up too much because it's going
to bump this parameter up because it
gets better perf out of it um so you
just have it until it bumps this
parameter up to hopefully fit all the
other
parameters which like it happens to do
in this case relatively well there a
couple quirks
work it should have an explicit
mechanism for
increasing increasing cost as it becomes
what
[Music]
I mean I guess that is actually what
happens to be fair because we have a
conservative bound on stuff
right wait a second we have a
conservative
bound if it's written in C can you not
like write a rapper M that runs multiple
versions of the environment across
threads or is it just not necessary uh
we have vectorization as well yeah we do
we have the best multi-processing out
there in fact so yes you can run you can
run a th000 environments per core and
you can run on 16 cores if you'd like in
fact we do that for a few of our
environments that are a little slower or
not even a little slower they have more
bandwidth really um but most of our
environments are just so fast that one
or two cores and you're
good mostly the ones are slow is the
ones that are slower just because we're
using like fancy opponent AI that takes
a while to compute
we'll get to improving those
though I mean you can go read any of our
environments they're all open source and
they're like they're one file a piece
they're super simple like people go ask
C you know I don't want to read C it's
really easy C like look at this so uh
puffer lib
ocean snake so this is massively
multi-agent snake I think this runs like
I don't know 5 10 million steps a second
this is the whole code 300 lines this is
logging this is the struct here's some
initialization here's your observation
function delete snake spawn snake spawn
food reset
step and rendering that's
it that's the whole
environment and then there's this this
just binds it to uh this is just an
intermediary that binds C to python via
cython it also runs the loop over over a
like mult multiple copies of the
environment and sets up buffers and
stuff and then snake. p is just a tiny
little stub that has uh you know the
binding that's
it there's no magic and they all look
like this pretty much like neural MMO is
one of the most complicated RL
environments out there and it's one file
it's going to be 3,000 lines 2800 lines
but just like one file of really simple
code so this scales as well you can go
from very very simple environments to
very very complicated environments like
this and they'll all be
fast neural mo3 is like 1.9 million
steps per second on One
Core it's a fun time come right to
environment with us
this year is a somewhat Less Fun Time
this is a bunch of math and it's hurting
my head
today but it's very
important so I will do
it there is kind of implicitly a time
management thing in
the absolute
performance is going to bias you towards
longer runs but only if you're confident
because it's a conservative
bound and because you start off running
shorter
runs you're not allowed to run longer
runs until you're confident
so I don't think you need to actually
penalize cost I think you already have
cost
penalized you have it penalized VI
uncertainty because it's not actually
bad to run high cost experiments it's
only bad to
run high cost experiments that you're
wrong about and don't do well you want
to run higher and higher cost
experiments in fact you want to run the
higher cost experiments ASAP as soon as
you're confident in them
I could experiment with an even more
conservative
bound I could do two standard deviation
bound that's like a really conservative
bound
right does that do anything for you
maybe let's see what this one is I don't
think that this is done very well let's
check I'd be surprised it's
theoretically it's poorly
motivated it's possible empirically it
does
okay where did I put it I have way too
many freaking Windows uh let's just
close some of these
there so
1,200 and 75
experiments where's our Pito
from the hell there it
is all right clean parito front but I
think that this is just lower perf
overall this is 1200
at it's 1,200 like
[Music]
versus
it yeah so this is the worst one and
it's still worse than this
this
one yeah there we
go so this is just not that
good not very good which is expected
because this doesn't make any
sense so get rid of
this and let's just
do let's just increase some parameters
this could
potentially change quite a
bit so this is our best right
now and this is like almost perfect
it could literally just be tuning some
scale parameters from here to be
know oh look at
that well these are going to be too
long to start with potentially
think you start the time even lower but
with a bigger scale
maybe it's a little
that dynamically growing the cost is
difficult
yeah dynamically growing the cost will
be
if I just do this based around like
total time steps
right the initial
samples are going to be around that time
scale the initial samples are going to
be like
100 I don't want to start at a 100
million but be randomly sampling 500
million that's going to take for
freaking ever
you really want a better way of
dynamically
growing growing the
compute you really want a much better
way of dynamically growing the compute
well to be fair I think the current
thing I have
initialization that's difficult right
like cuz I think that the method I have
at the
moment it should actually work very well
it's just keeping the
with you could penalize cost uncertain
cost
actually if you penalize cost when there
is uncertainty that could fix it
yeah I think that actually might be the
way because that will prevent you that
will like push your uh that should push
your runs to the bottom of the time
scale at the start of training
window L
penalty this is CLA
Max of
one cost variance over cost
so this is a lot so if the variance is a
lot
variance what is stupid Claude is really
stupid um
I mean the people saying that like this
is good it says more about the people
the the people than it does about Claude
CU like oh you're not prompting it right
no it's just
wrong hey
welcome bitching about math and code and
stuff I've been working on this hyperr
algorithm all day uh it's been a lot of
math hurt my had a whole bunch we're
very close to having it they're just a
couple last
tweaks actually this run here is looking
pretty
good just gets
yeah I mean I'm mostly checking to make
sure I'm not doing utterly stupid things
but then the thing is it gives me
utterly stupid things in reply so at
least it checks that I'm paying
attention but like
literally it's giving me the opposite
I've asked it like for very simple
formulas and it's like it's giving me
the opposite like five times in a row
oh you know wait hold
on did my message get lost yeah
sometimes restream eats messages if you
don't see it here I don't see it let me
see yeah it doesn't even show up in the
uh the other chat
window so if you're m message isn't
there I don't see
dumb uh when I open Twitter yeah I have
um I got I don't think I have claw muted
I might I have cursor muted as a keyword
because the cursor people are even worse
it's like I don't know how to program
but now I must be a genius because I can
type things to into a language
model my favorite is the like oh yeah
we're going to replace the programmers
because we use cursor it's like dude you
couldn't even learn how to program you
think that like you you think that
because you're typing things into a
language model that there's actually
some skill involved in typing things
into a there's
not there's no skill involved in using a
language model there isn't at least not
relative to literally any other like
anything
else and not only that if there is any
skill it will rapidly decrease in value
as the models get better because you
will no longer have to coax them into
doing the thing you want they will just
do
it it's very funny
but it's okay because in the puffer
Discord we write RL environments and
see that generally scares away the
people that don't actually want to
think which is very funny because it's
not very difficult it's actually great
writing these Ms and C it's like really
easy and really fun and really
fast decreasing value part
yeah of course
I mean you think prompting is going to
be a thing forever no it's an artifact
of the model
sucking as the models get better if you
ask a question in any remotely sane way
it will give you the same answer I mean
like if you ask a smart person a
question in like any way that makes
sense they're going to understand what
you mean and they're going to give you
like at least a decent
it I don't know I just generally try not
to interact with the language model
space very
much particularly not the language model
wrapper
space I to convert to mold rust code
into scon via claw and just gave me a
headache prior C stuff I I do not like
rust I am not a rust enjoyer rust is
very complicated it gets in my way and
it gives me headaches and makes think
too much C is very simple it's very fast
it does not get my way and it is so
easy I very much like
see I don't know if this CLA penalty
makes sense
you probably should have this be
continuous function as well
I had a flow of compiling it
ready that's why I used it since I
haven't used it for a few years come
back and it's not been
fun if you're trying to do fun RL things
come look at our puffet code you will
have more
fun I also don't recommend converting
the scon I like scon when I started
using it I still like it as an
intermediary layer but honestly these
days it's literally easier and faster to
write C than
scon it took all of two weeks to get
used to it and then it was
easier literally the only thing you need
to know is that the F sanitized Flags
exist tried to hack it together because
I wanted to remove the rest of yeah rust
is like man you know what rust reminds
me of rust reminds me of when I ran Arch
Linux on like a crazy water cooled
desktop for four years in undergrad
until eventually one day I installed an
update without checking it it crashed
the entire system and bricked it like
that's what it reminds me of it's like a
very tricky technical thing for people
who want to play around with tricky
things until ultimately bites you and
you decide that you want things to work
I no longer like tricky
problems I like simple things that solve
important
problems every so often I have to do
something moderately complicated to
solve an important
problem like what today but I try to
keep those few and far between because
this has been truly exhausting
you still learn tons and you still get
tons of stuff done I've improved more in
the last year and I've gotten more done
in the last year than in the last
several years I mean it's really
been we shipped 20,000 lines of code in
the last update with puffer lip the
20,000 lines of C
and now with this we're hopefully going
to ship the best hyperparameter
algorithm we'll see how well this
transfers off the synthetic Benchmark to
the real rlms but uh I know I'm
confident this run I'm looking at here
on above me is also looking pretty good
since finding your repo Runo I feel like
I learned a bunch of stuff right hey I
mean hang out in the Discord like I'm in
there in voice half the time in the
evenings if I'm not on the stream and uh
there are lots of people there are just
building cool RL
environments it's the best way to get
into this
stuff I review all if you want to
contribute Ms by the way like I code
revie every single contributed M like on
stream it's what you get if you
contribute
variance I'm just going to describe it
and see if claude's really this
stupid for
actually might we see though hey up to
you and yeah folks please do Star Puffer
on GitHub it really helps me out a ton
it's
free I gave Claud C custom instructions
then it added an additional sense to the
start as per your
already star very good the puffer thanks
you for your
support he eats Stars you know feed the
puffer
I'm not reading that [ __ ]
[Music]
anyways Max
what do you want this function to
do I want it to be a cost
penalty um it should penalize you if
your cost is it should penalize you for
select a high cost when you have high
uncertainty about the cost so the
function has to go to one when your cost
certainty which is the standard
deviation is below a specific threshold
and then it has to smoothly it has to be
a continuous function that scales up
based on the cost from
there this is
close the only thing is that this is
which does require you to subtract the
threshold from the scaling
that's a Max of
zero and standard
[Music]
deviation does that work I don't know if
that
works if that does work then I'm
incredibly tired for not figuring that
out let me see but I don't think it does
so
cost times the max
yeah that's a bad
idea you should keep it linear there's
no reason to square
that
um I've been staring at this map all
day
well the only thing there is the
standard deviation minus
the
threshold I think you have to divide by
threshold if you do that no we're not
[ __ ] exponentiating it either [ __ ]
that
um I think it might be hold
on cost times
0.5 I think that fixes the thing where
because you subtract the
threshold well
because you're scaling it down by
subtracting the threshold from the
standard deviation
right you have to do that to have the
threshold but you're scaling down the
standard
deviation I guess wait the one plus kind
of covers
I think we'll try
this how's uh this sweep
going it looks like this one's going
pretty damn
so uh this is better than
before this is better than my previous
best but it's got this weird
artifact so this got to 2900 by the very
end
it's developed by SF Bros who think
they're very high
EQ it's literally like these language
models are developed by the most out of
touch people people you will ever
meet okay so this is actually great
right here this
is this is like
fantastic but this is weird as
[ __ ]
so okay so this is very good right here
so that it like it latches on to you see
how quickly it transitions now to High
Time steps this is very good
I've seen this before but not with this
acquisition function so yeah batch size
immediately gets this immediately gets
manyi
batches learn rate is much closer
actually
yeah much closer this is spot
on so that's somehow
fixed uh gamma is also
fixed Lambda is
bizarre there's always one parameter off
it's weird lambda's way
off Lambda is supposed to be 0.95 so I
have no idea how it drifts like this we
can adjust the scales and [ __ ] though
update epox is good BPT Horizon is good
here n Ms is good here I don't know why
it's down here this is very weird these
ones are
good and then cost is like this oh wait
but this is actually a Pito front
I thought it was going to give us the
weird curve again but this is actually
good um yeah this is actually very
good so these points
here AB 12 27 like this is very very
very nice for a Pito front here I don't
know why there's nothing
here I guess cuz it's so confident about
the parito front that it just doesn't
have
to um
cost oh you know what this is I know
what this
is this is resampling Paro
points okay I'm dumb okay this is
resampling paredo points there's a
resample argument to carbs that will
randomly resample a paredo
point that's all this
is so this is a benchmark that's now I
don't know if it's full solved is the
only thing it's almost full solved but
it missed one parameter learning rate
let me try this
um this cost
penalty I don't even think we need this
to be honest now cuz this is so good but
many Bruns are we at Are we almost done
with this I can just do this in a
separate tab right
long my break
point I could have just set the ARs to
be faster
estimate CAU
ciruit model
outputs
cost where the hell's cost
variance still in Florida yep I'm going
to be here a while
I uh I come back to California when it
gets too hot here or
whatever and uh there's a new facility
even before then there's a new facility
I've got to set up with the servers for
puffer yeah also that it's going to
literally be like six months of hard
training to get my health back I lost 18
pounds in like four weeks or three weeks
even
I got some dumbbells here that I'm
waiting until Monday to lift so I don't
hurt myself after the uh antibiotics and
stuff and I've got um a nice power rack
coming in a few
weeks can we talk about the new facility
do have the engineering design it's
pretty well
covered um it's going to have 20
standard Outlets
the power uh the power will be good for
two boxes per Outlet so 40 box
capacity air conditioning is all handled
we've got a guy that's done server
setups before for
it
um yeah it's pretty well set
well no he's just planning like the AC
and the the AC and
stuff no no no that's just like the
cooling and stuff of it to make sure
that we have sufficient AC
um I mean it's not crazy complicated
because they're just they're desktop
class machines you just need 20 Outlets
sufficient power we got a good ups for
it with some power conditioning
it's not really a ton of network [ __ ]
um there's really not a ton of network
[ __ ] to do they're individual boxes
we're still not planning on wiring
together there needs to be Network
shut there definitely needs to be better
monitoring on the boxes but that's just
what we stick on the docker images
machines if we need Network look if if
we need Network [ __ ] we I'll just get
link key
right if there needs to be Network [ __ ]
I'll get linky right
I'll ask him if he thinks there's going
to be I'll yeah I'll ask him the next
time uh we're on voice if he thinks
there's going to be anything substantial
to
do but the thing is like they're not
networked like uh they're not networked
like servers would be networked
bet like we're not sticking AFS on them
they don't need High speed like
multimachine inter
connects I mean I'd like to get a 10
gigabit connection I don't know if we
can even get a 10 gab connection there
though for
functional I mean the main thing that's
gone wrong with the small cluster is
just the micro code [ __ ]
right and I'll talk to linky the next
time we're in
voice slow
internet well I don't know what we're
going to be able to do about that I
don't know if we can get um 10 gigabit
out there I might have to bandwidth
optimize and really the only thing that
you
do is um is wan be or
Neptune which I can bandwidth optimize
puffer for that just by packing stuff
tighter
there's internet there's at least a
gigabit I just don't know if we get 10
gabit I yeah I can do starlink but I
think that's
worse I can get it as a backup no
problem though
I look we'll talk let me finish this
this is
important
um what the [ __ ] is where's the cost
variance
here where the hell is the cost variance
now Target bear is
different
right yeah see this is surrogate to
surrogate output
ooh look at
this very very good 3200 that's that's a
new
record who is messaging me on Discord
good
job
yeah I mean that's freaking good
yeah that's real good I don't know what
it is at the very end let's see what it
discovers at the very
end think this is
fine the gamma I guess it fits gamma oh
it fits gamma and Lambda a little bit
better at the very end so we got to
figure out why these things don't fit
properly like it it misses a few
parameters for too long
this is close to Optimal
though what m is this this is a
synthetic test
this has cost
variance
I think it's it's 30 it's 3,000
something it's pretty close to what
we're
at like I said it's just a synthetic
test but
this could just be like
Randomness that doesn't
scale but to give you an idea that
like original carbs was getting maybe a
third of Max score in 200 runs and it
was like hard plateaued at a third of
Max
score so we have dramatically improved
this algorithm
um at least on the synthetic task right
we're assuming that it
transfers if this like if this actually
transfers to our other environments
we're basically we'll have solved hyper
pram sweeps for RL or at least like
improved it several fold in the course
of a day and a
half I high score I think it's 3500 I
think I
checked I can double check in a bit but
I think it's like
3500 like I said it's a synthetic task
so I mean all it does is it assigns you
it assigns optimal values to the hyper
parameters um it defines like absolute
value distance penalty from those
parameters and then it sets some some
scaling parameters for um for cost
it's
roughly models an RL problem but there's
no noise in
it so all your estimates are
perfect I think we're not going to need
this this extra little bit here I think
we're just going to tune parameters and
be
good I mean potentially cost penalty is
kind of a reasonable thing to
worse the way it biases cost isn't
amazing
great I mean the parito front looks
pretty
nice it is doing lowcost runs which is
what you want
lambda's fit
correctly gamma's fit
correctly might want to give it a little
time it's actually kind of doing the
correct thing
is you don't just take into account
score here
um ideally what you want is you want
your algorithm to run a ton of really
fast experiments until it's very
confident that it understands how all
the hyper parameters scale and then it
runs like a couple midscale experiments
to make sure that its fit is correct and
then it runs the big experiments quite
quickly so you want to spend most of
your most of your experiment count on
Fast
experiments uh it shouldn't need early
stopping you could technically do it but
the thing is this is It's cost aware so
it's supposed to actually
um it's actually supposed to do that
itself early stopping is more for random
search and such
okay I mean there's potentially more to
do
working these higher cost runs aren't
trans in to better
perf I mean the ideal algorithm is going
to run a bunch of experiments at 50
yes so this does not
work that's
fine we'll go back to the old one
let me just go look at the parameters
real
quick see if I can figure something
out we you total time
steps so 0.5 right
yeah these look fine I don't know why I
get stuck in weirdly weird
spots possibly needs more random trials
to be
I want to make sure I'm on the right
track at the very least
funny no wonder there's so many freaking
breakout results
and actually we can
adjust total time
STS can adjust
uh to time steps
are you aware of some resource on how
python executes CM scon code what calls
it makes not very vers than
this what calls just check our uh our
repository if you're looking for how to
bind stuff to see
like every single one of these
environments is an example
like
look so we
have here's
breakout you import the scyon file
right and the scon file includes
theh from C so scon service is an
intermediary that also runs the loopover
environments and then as for how this
gets compiled
right for local compilation for testing
in p c with no python we've got build
ocean.
sh and then for uh binding to C we have
static linking in setup.py so this gets
statically linked and setup.py
and you have the uh you know the
extension and the arguments here
that a super a weird suspicion that my
module is having prefer performance
issues due to type
conversions
tles well yeah we don't pass tles back
and forth to see you have to go through
through the stupid Pi object API for
that we use numpy arrays and then you
pass numpy arrays through scon and you
actually end up passing them as pointers
so you'd populate memory just directly
through C pointers and there's zero
overhead zero overhead zero
conversion this is again this is all in
the example environment if you read like
any single one of the example
environments you'll see exactly how we
do everything
I'm aware of passing buffers for args
I'm a bit
confused in case is not exactly running
m
the tldr is you don't want to go through
the piop API very often if you have to
go through it at
all love that you're still going after
this hard well done thank
you yeah this is going to be I this is
this is all I'm doing um we are going to
fix reinforcement
learning it will be
fixed it will be painful to get done but
it will happen
okay so now we have neoc
carbs running
breakout and running
Palm so this may require some
fiddling but this should be a a decent
Benchmark this will be 400
[Music]
experiments then
what I mean if I actually can solve
reinforcement learning I should
literally be solving hundreds of
problems around industry and making a
huge impact on the overall state of AI
um you'd imagine that I make a fair bit
of money along the way there it'd be
pretty hard not to if I actually get
that working properly and if somehow
that still doesn't get us to long-term
like super intelligence or whatever then
I don't know I'll pick the next cursed
area of science to fix right and start
like and start another lab around that
with even less like even less reason to
have to have it be
that but for the time being I'm focused
on fixing RL growing puffer as a company
um releasing good code pretty much that
and getting my damn Health back geez
pneumonia kicked my
ass made it
it has to be pointed to Matrix
data
what you just do a flat array it doesn't
matter matter how many dimensions your
array has it's just a it's just a flat
buffer pointer and
issue exactly read it as you
wish C is just a great
language I love me some
C python not bad
either um binding python to see and
getting them to play nice together is
kind of a pain in the ass
oh yeah no there are totally direct
Python and C bindings that's a thing um
usually you end up having to stick
shitty python API stuff into your SE
though or you have to up sticking a
bunch of types information into your
python so that's why we have the
intermediary layer we use it as the loop
over M's and use it to hide all the
stupid conversion logic so it doesn't
pollute our python or pollute our
C where are they it's just C types you
can just do it with C
types I don't think it's worth it based
on what I know now I could be wrong you
can do it
look at
that neoc
carbs pretty much everything to numpy
and then pass to buffer is usually the
best way to
go it's really easy that
way you can even pass like specific St
points as as numpy slice it's pretty
nice got home from drinking wine and nap
and the hack have a good night see you
Monday thank
you see you
around I don't drink much anymore I
don't have any fun really I just got to
do all
this that's yeah again read like look at
our sideon for this we do this
everywhere like our stuff is kind of
even fancier than that we allocate a
giant tensor of observation buffers in
shared memory and then we split the
offsets to that shared memory buffer
across cores and then on each core we
split that portion of shared memory
across individual environments and give
all those individual pointers to uh to
different C
structs and then all of these different
uh environments like 4,000 environments
or whatever on different cores just
right into contiguous memory uh and it's
just
perfect that's how puffer so fast with
all this
nice where's the shared memory stuff
implemented in Puffer in the
multiprocessing vector.
multiprocessing you can look at it uh we
do have as far as I'm aware we have the
fastest uh General vectorization
implementation for reinforcement
learning it's a very nice implementation
it supports gymnasium it supports
petting zoo and it supports our native
end format even
work has a bunch of nice tricks and if
you're interested in reading about it
there's um I have a blog post on puffer
doai just click the blog that describes
all the optimizations in there there's
also the white paper it's there as
well this is biasing towards two uh two
fast of runs I
go in Duro you cut 780
lines might not be
working switching in it and
reset yeah go figure out what you broke
Enduro it's going to be funny because
you're eventually going to get it down
to roughly the length that I expected
when I gave you the project okay 1400 is
still more than I
expected to give
you I was hoping to give you like an 800
line
project and maybe it won't get to 800
that's kind of
ambitious I mean if I did it maybe I
could get it to
800 that'd be pretty tight though maybe
more like a
thousand
2300 well the 2300 was
ridiculous now you're at least like
reasonably know reasonably close I'd say
I could definitely make it
1,200 I don't know about lower than
that if I really went through your
logic I'm pretty
confident exactly
like come on you look at my other code
I've spent like a day and a half on this
and it looks like we're going to
revolutionize hyper parameter
tuning can get a lot done pretty quick
when I've uh I'm locked
in hope I'm hoping that this works on
these Ms we will
see I'm not too bothered that this is
taking a bunch of initial runs because I
set it to very very fast runs we'll see
though use it on every real that's what
I'm doing I got pong and breakout here
these are both running I got these
running on two
boxes the breakout run should be longer
and more stable the pong is like a quick
test I don't mind if pong takes a ton of
runs because the runs are really
quick these are literally like 10 10 to
20 second experiments
go oh look at that we got a 11 million
step run that's already at 12
score all right that looks nice
8:45 I mean this
is look at the time steps it's launching
we train for 20 million in our Baseline
okay so it's launching really cheap
experiments here this was an intentional
test to see if you can boot strap off
really cheap keep
experiments the breakout ones will be
substantially more
expensive look at that it's already at
80 though with this
one I want to see how this behaves we're
going to
see over
time yeah that's a great that's a great
thing to do actually here we'll do a
quick session on the uh on the Discord
it'll be on stream but I'll hop in the
Discord real quick while I like slowly
fall into this chair exhausted
cool uh is desktop audio
on should
be got to go left so I can get those
base dude I like these used to be good
like these used to be pretty impressive
it's all gone it
sucks oh I guarantee I guarantee Joseph
you are way stronger than Jeff
Bezos well yeah but still
we'll be back we'll be back pear in 40
soon
enough don't don't please don't push it
n it'll take a few months where's
bcer yeah where the [ __ ] is
he bro Bros chill he I actually you do
that I'm gonna grab a drink because I di
dehydrated let me go grab a drink be
right back I'll link in general chat
you're
good what up bet yo I don't know worked
all [ __ ] day got a
lift I think I did the 3D com right not
100% convinced but yeah well we're about
to find out right
you said you're on Lincoln General chat
I don't see it though uh the voice chat
The Voice Channel
General and they got they got to rename
that or fix
it I think you can rename any of these
like in a second I think you could just
call voice chat I've got mod but I have
no mod po
so I don't know if that was attentional
it's it's a little confusing like like
the actual options in Discord are like
pretty
pretty difficult to uh understand
I ask my
quiet he leaves and shuts the door right
away
good all right I linked it in uh the
voice
chat I'm reading it
now it's frankly pretty good let's see
the voice
chat yeah should I I guess pop up on
Twitch to watch what you're doing and
then just mute my mute the volume I
guess pop
up or yeah that probably
best oh here it is Tower climb at the
bottom
good I got up at like 8 and I've just
been coding this thing you got up at 8
because I saw you were streaming at
like was I
streaming like I I'm pretty
early super early like I've been
streaming for a minute
6:45 was it 6:4 I don't think I was up
that
early no I think it
was 13
hours 646 it says 13 hours ago it's 6
6:46 was the time I have the email okay
I can prove it so it's 13 hours ago and
I was I've been [ __ ] doing
from a short walk and meals I've been
streaming and coding the whole time the
whole time so I mean I got a lot done
though like I I redid half the math of
carbs
so where's the Discord Channel
freaking there we
go I readed half the math of carbs in
that time I'm so what do we have here
we've got
really just super simple I think I think
layering it will still work on this
we'll see so you have
one is it one channel by default okay
CNN
channels three stri
one what's the size of the
window uh 6X 6 by 8 yeah then this is
good do
this what's this
size oh okay so this is if you compute
it here so this is
128 256 okay this is a little
big I might make this the I might cut
this in half go
128 well this cuz this is look this is
32 for
128 256 6 52 so that's getting a little
big I might do this one I could do 16
instead of
32 and then it would be uh five was it
256 256 I you try both of them because
that might screw it up because it's not
that many channels but we'll see then
you have
flattened the heck is this a flat it's
the player obs
yeah you can do this I always with these
projection layers um I'm always tempted
to just like feed this into the lstm but
I think there's some quirks if you try
to do uh different input and hidden size
for the lstm so this is fine and then
this I assume that you copied this and
this with these two standard deviations
are correct and if so that's fine en
code observations
board player
view uh hopefully you've checked this to
make sure that this is in the correct
order okay so I wanted to talk to you
about that in the case of this puzzle
environment would it materially matter
if it's like 6X 8X 6 or 6X you know what
any combination of this because it's
just being passed in as one giant 1D
like yes it does
matter because you're taking that ond
data
and you're restructuring it into 3D have
you ever like [ __ ] up image processing
and like transposed like the rows and
columns or whatever and you just get
like a corrupted
mess see like one
time I've done that yeah you you need to
you need to actually just like open this
thing like go look at this thing and
make sure that this is the observation
that you expect
this network is
fine wait
what oh yeah Network flat and then you
Pudge cat Pudge this is fine and then I
made a a slight lstm modification to
make the input 256 um that was something
that I had to do in order for it to work
yeah that's
fine what happened when before what like
it didn't work with 128 if yeah so the
default of the lstm in the if you under
recurrent is expects a 128 input so you
have to make
a did you try it with 128 first or did
you just go to
256 well I tried to just run it without
having like the super class and then um
well you have to change this hidden size
has to be 128 if you're going to do that
but no okay no I haven't tried it with
128 I just tried it with 256 start you
should try you should try both if it's
if 128 Works it'll run faster it be
better yeah so 256 it actually during
this I tried to train some and it did
start to learn so I hopefully presume
that means that a lot of things are
working um well that could be the comp
not the 256 you know know sure but I was
gonna say is the speed the speed got
tanked yeah how long is it how fast is
it 560 from 1 million
plus oh and how big is the
net uh 690k parameters it's about right
you that's about you you made a bigger
Network what do you
expect well I wouldn't expect it to cut
it in half but then what do you mean you
wouldn't expect to cut it down you went
from 150k parameters to 600k like
because if it's it's basically like
mostly Network that's taking up the time
so I suppose it should be yeah my n is
0% every everything is in train yes that
was yeah so the Net's a little big as
all okay so secondary question here
expensive
I mean this is pretty much hardcoded for
level one how would you recommend I set
it up to do Dynamic based off of the the
level sizes the level sizes changed from
level to level like it won't necessarily
always be a 6X 6 by8 it could
potentially Global Ops you do local Ops
you give it you give it a 3D crop around
the uh around the
player okay so just do some like some
reasonable crop um up to yeah you're
going to have to play around with how
big how far you need to see you should
probably just figure out like if you
play the game how far you need to see in
order to actually still play it so a
little tradeoff there so so here's kind
of like a slightly weird part right cuz
like if when you're playing the actual
game like visually you can
determine I guess some degree of depth
uh when you're looking at it m i mean
you for sure need to see like the full
width of the
screen and
then I mean you can argue that you don't
need to see entirely up but I guess up
in the game you don't even you don't see
the whole thing in the game the camera's
kind of zoomed in in in the puzzle mode
of which this is kind of extracting some
levels from you can for the mo you can
see pretty close but I I get what you
mean I'll make a window that seems
pretty reasonable and then probably like
I don't know five maybe seven by seven
by whatever yeah and sure and so instead
of having it centered on player I I
would presume I'd Center it like maybe
one like two above player because you
really don't need to look at below you
realistically you can do
that and that's all that would all be
within the N logic right that during
that well it's within it's all in
compute observations as all yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay so I could do that and
then run a fresh sweep n nuke all like
the previously kind of somewhat
understood parameters because now we're
on a 3D con
you can keep your parameters and then
what you do is you make the graphs in
the dashboard and you see if the best
runs are at the edge of any of your
ranges and if they're at the edge of
your range then you have to expand the
range okay you know what I mean that I
mean I presume if like all of the
parameters are it's shooting for are all
like you know say if it's I set a range
from 09 to 0.95 and all them are at 094
999 then expand it
so I can do that from an early test I
did notice that it was able to achieve a
higher score in a much quicker time
frame but it has not been able to beat
the game
yet it has not been able to what you are
far away and
quiet yeah the local Ops crop might
actually help
you what I one thing that I was thinking
about in terms of like a reward
engineering thing and you know was
what if I rewarded it for various
patterns that like the game shows you as
like useful techniques instead of just
like the most basic like saying like you
get rewarded for going up and you get
penalized for going down yeah probably
too complicated to be honest I wouldn't
bother I wouldn't bothering that much I
think you'll just I think you'll just
get it you if you want to spend time on
anything you might do like the random
level stuff that' probably be fun for
you sure
I reward ship for weeks is just not fun
or
useful yeah I mean I at least want to
see if I can get this to beat at least
the first level pretty cleanly easily
and get there see how well it does on
maybe like two or three levels and then
I'll mess with the PG stuff where you
just like dunk in like
10,000 hopefully this this sweep stuff
is better we'll
see oh kind these sces aren't great yet
but also i' I've set it to like really
fast runs only it's trying to build up a
predictive model at the moment I don't
know about these batch
sizes or these mini
batches we'll see what it's doing
here yeah I guess I see what you mean
when I asked you a couple days ago to
and you're like yeah don't worry too
much about the policy stuff because it's
like you mentioned it's like not very
complicated really not right to set up
this one I mean I think I only spent
like an hour or two kind of messing with
it and then really not that was start
training it'll be less than an hour or
two once you get better it would take
you 20
minutes
sure we'll
see so did you see the carb stuff I've
been
doing I haven't been able to really
follow it throughout today so um what
kind of I know you said you're like
redoing the math but can you dive like a
little bit as an explanation or catch me
up a little bit Yeah so is this thir
good one yeah so this
is basically a full solve of a synthetic
hyper parameter tuning task with the
cleanest the cleanest progress curve
you've ever seen on a hyper parameter
sweep yeah I mean it looks pretty nasty
to
me that like typically it's just like
all over the freaking place so these are
this is like consistent
Improvement these points here these are
resampled points these are resampled
parito optimal points so it's basically
it's checking its
work um this is look different from like
the curves that I have it starts right
here you can see it starts off with
really fast runs and then it gets
confident and it just very quickly goes
to very long runs cuz in this case
that's what gives you perf so you see
right around here it gets this last perf
bump yeah um it's got you know hyper
prems very latched on very quickly the
optimal there are a couple small quirks
where it doesn't get everything quite
perfect like Lambda for instance for
some reason it has Lambda too high up
until the very end um but it pretty much
just gets everything very quickly with a
few small
exceptions and this is the Pito front
you can see there like a few misses but
out of 200 runs it's basically a perfect
parito front with a few like a few
misses over
here
um so
yeah
so on
a go forward basis when I'm kind of
working more on the science side stuff
the stuff I did today would be
absolutely hard as [ __ ] this took every
this took like most of what I knew um
understood this is to give you an idea
the carbs hyper pram sweep algorithm has
three different gaussian processes that
are used for various things uh it has
several probabilistic reings and several
kind of weird uh space Transformations
for various types of parameters and
2,000 lines of code that probably should
be around 700 lines of code um so I
redesigned like half of the math on this
algorithm based off of just like staring
through the paper for a very long time
sure I first of all I fixed their space
Transformations that was kind of the
initial thing that got me
started I a lot of their mask a lot of
their like their candidate sample
filtering I replaced with clam
I got rid of this search term entirely
based off of some analysis I did
I completely changed this acquisition
function clamping thing I replaced this
with a a completely different
function and there were a few other
changes as
well so yeah like this is a whole new
algorithm at this
point um
it works we'll see whether we'll see how
well it transfers to the real RL tasks
but the original algorithm fails a very
basic synthetic task and the uh the new
one crushes it uh why would it fail a
basic task there are lots of issues with
the
algorithm and if you look at this so if
you look at this here's the thing that
doesn't make sense right they say that
this is like really good in this Crush
has all these benchmarks but if you look
at the
RL all these different algorithms
including carbs lose to Asha as's a
really [ __ ]
algorithm that's what the sh stands
for no it's um it's basically Asha Asha
is literally just a random search with
adaptive compute so like you can get an
upper you can do like an upper bound on
Asha just by doing like the number of
Random sech trials that Asha is going to
do for the full number of time
steps so like is hebo any good or is
that like yeah hebo is good but carbs is
built on hebo so carbs should be better
than hebo okay lower is better here so
carbs is better carbs is better and then
carbs is better so so those these they
don't have they don't have the uh GitHub
for like the the testing do they they
don't have that code available they sent
me some of it but the thing is it's
really slow they ran this like at
massive scale yeah I bet it yeah
exactly so but the thing is because they
ran this at massive scale look all of
their experiments were at like at least
a 100 times slower than ours actually
like a thousand times slower for a lot
of them so my expectation is even though
they have a fair number of gpus we're
actually going to run more experiments
than they are on like two gpus because
our stuff is so fast which is kind of
cool right
well it makes sense to uh some which
means we get better results right we
we're able to actually test it
properly which which things can't we
test on
there oh all the tasks they use are
slow are there any things that that that
are not going to be testable using the
using
a uh puffer native environment no we
we'll just test like puffer native
versus original carbs and we'll be good
so so those those particular it doesn't
matter to test on those particular tests
that they've tested on no they just ch
some like they just chose some standard
RL Tas that run 5,000 steps a
second
H doesn't matter at
all it would be nice to have direct
comparison we'll just Test original
carbs on our environments right yeah
yeah you
can it doesn't matter
but well it's potentially maybe
application specific
yeah it
n well again look this is these are
these are still very short runs this is
pong is uh without frame Skip and we're
only doing like this is was 14 million
or whatever so 69 runs let's go we'll
see if it does in 200 if not I'll up the
budget a little bit Y is this the exact
same setting that you were just using
for yeah okay same setting minus the
different total time step config and
then breakout has a larger budget
because breakout takes longer so we'll
see we'll see how this does it's a
little iffy because some of these tasks
are very like seed dependent and stuff
so we'll see how it does on these but
should be
interesting linky am I am I like totally
missing that there's a bunch of
complicated stuff I'm not anticipating
with a
cluster linky talk please
[Applause]
um wor sorry sorry my my kid's going to
be loud um but the worry is
scale yeah
honestly because look at all the little
problems you're having with like six
boxes well the main problem having six
boxes is microne to be
fair
um I wouldn't say fully
100% I mean changes by the way they're
all going to be air cooled so we're not
going to have to deal with broken water
coolers that's good that's probably good
when you have that many machines
honestly
um yeah
desktops really layout's going to be a
pain you're going to have to figure that
out it's just along one
wall yeah but you're also going to have
to verify on every box that your air is
Flowing the correct way and you want to
split it into a
hot he said he said a guy's going to do
that I I think we should be I mean we're
going to we have like we'll have pretty
good AC in there and
ventilation it doesn't matter I mean
imagine if you have every band pointing
in the same direction and you just have
a row of boxes down the center of the
room you need you need to have a a like
probably a air flow that's that's
sweeping the the hot the hot air away
and cooler air that's flowing in through
the front you're going to have enough
bans in enough boxes in there to
actually affect the total room current
like air
circulation keep that in mind where dep
what I will go I will go through it and
look at the the layout suggested um also
think about Network
redundancy um I could get a backup with
stlink if we need
it I think that's a good idea uh I don't
the one thing is I don't know if we can
get 10 gigabit there because it's like
it's on a far so I don't know if we can
get like 10 gigabit to to there or if
it's going to be one we'll
see here's the thing like do you
imagine gig do you imagine gigabytes
going through through it and short
amount of time like we might just put
some monitoring on there and yell at
anybody that's doing too much
logging well yeah there is that I think
that's smart but then it might even be
wise to say how about you look at a
network attached storage for all of them
and just partition that off to each
machine and I really don't want to do I
really don't want to do shared file
system for these machines it's a pain in
the ass
uh that's fine I was going to say uh
you're going to have to set up logging
on each individual machine oh no so for
that we'll
do uh we'll do something for that um the
question is what well those can just be
installed over the local network right
that's like anable or
um maybe okay I'm sorry I just dropped
off the face of the Earth
um and just amable or something for like
uh just like loing images on all of them
um we just like I spend some time making
sure I got a good base image and I just
flash on
everything you can automate that all you
want really what I mean
is first of all setting up a log server
you're going to want that you're going
to want some Central Point that way like
you can't expect to get logged through
and machine that's down so before it
goes down at least have it send off like
oh [ __ ] I'm panicking yeah
um that box should
have like electrical segregation from
the rest you want that to be the last
one that goes
down um the reason why I'm
Pro like I'm not saying run everything
off of like shared
storage what I should say is you should
have a shared storage for a few reasons
one of which is it'll make automating
the process of installing way
easier
um passing files between boxes like you
need to say hey these this group of 10
boxes need to do this specific thing now
you can just iterate over all the boxes
with one command from one file
space um
yeah it's just when you get people
shared storage access they [ __ ] up
shared storage
access I've seen this happen I've seen
this happen in every academic cluster
ever and it's just [ __ ] cancer it's
so bad
yeah maybe like a
pseudo like root Administration or
M
um can I literally just
like you don't even need that just to
flash images though
right well you don't wanna you do not
want you want images you can Network
boot so you don't even need like a whole
network attached storage but ideally you
have something on the network that says
like hey this is an image you can just
Network boot
from uh either that or you know you're
going to go to each and every box with a
flash drive and manually well no not not
a flash drive I was I was hoping to just
load
can I not just load the image onto the
boxes over the
network or something and answer will
take care of
that yeah but you're talking about
like operating systems not just like
software that's gonna I don't
know access yeah I don't know how to set
that up we will see what state are you
in by the way
Missouri Missouri I think that's far
what state is this in Missouri M I don't
know where Missouri is me big very
stupid the middle to the middle yeah
north of Texas and then go to the right
a little bit I'm like right above
Louisiana you want a map of the United
States not just very stupid where where
States and own
country Texas lisana go north of
Louisiana me man it's not
terrible okay it's going to be in
Maryland so technically if everything
goes to [ __ ] I could just fly you into
Maryland and pay you for however long it
takes now you're in the spot that I
don't know where's
Maryland H Joseph what are you are you
are you guys serious right now like El
Bros like listen I
Tik Tok Zoomers but it should not be a
thing here I know Louisiana up
to
know I agree no one cares
but well you have to realize I grew up
in Texas neas I've been doing this all
day I just I just recoded an entire
complicated ass Hy parameter algorithm
in a day it's like [ __ ]
off yeah no I don't know where the
states
are um I know where the big states are
that's all that
matters okay yeah so there should be
Central
logging there needs to be Central Lo log
a log server that things automatically
report to so you can go to one place to
get all the logs uh that's probably good
we gotta be careful with bandwith you
need you need just okay well you need to
figure out the bandwidth first and
foremost then because that's that's
going to be crucial otherwise it
unusable you can't have 40 people
running well hold on it should
be I should be able to put 10ig
ethernet this is a slippery slope when
when I come to thinking things because
then I'm like why don't I own you know
selfhosted version of
like nocturn or whatever it is I think a
lot of these they try to charge you out
the ass to self
host well you can find like data
plotting things like that that you can
just my point is that you the thing is
there's no point s hosting it because
it's not going to be any faster and none
of the data is private it won't be
better don't care and it'll be a pain in
the ass to to deal
with um we're not in we're not in the
security business we're in the RL bus
it's not the security business it is
quite literally your outbound throughput
do you want to send your gigabytes worth
of data
for your internet the alternative I just
like I do a very I do a very very small
amount of bandwidth optimization on
puffer lib and then it's going to just
be sending out like you know a kilobyte
a minute or whatever yeah no you get a
firewall in layer three switches you can
just set bandwidth limits you need you
need you need a a switcher you need a
good switch uh like a
gigabit switch well if you're talking
about like structure you want every box
to have two ethernet ports you want both
that way you have redundant lines to a
set of two different switches that
are pretty much together uh configured
in a stack and then both of those talk
to a firewall through again redundant
lines I think I only have I only have
the way it's getting wired at the moment
there's only one ethernet to
each um add and you know it should not
go through a consumer grade router
either it needs to go through a
proper uh well no you could get away
with a p we get we don't want to get
away like you have to picture a use case
where there are you know
M things it's really not that crazy this
is not this is not like insane internet
uptime uh reliability like the as long
as the boxes stay alive they'll just
reconnect to Neptune or WB whenever so
that's not a big issue we're going to
have a UPS so they don't actually go
down from Power surges or like out like
short outages there's a generator as
well so we're fine there okay um the
only thing is like going to have crazy
bandwidth we're really not going to have
crazy bandwidth and we're not doing
crazy multimachine stuff so it's really
not that bad okay well uh you we're
getting you a firewall because you can
build one really cheap since you don't
like a 16 gigabyte Rams on a firewall
that's insane like I
run I think 4 gab of RAM and four core
TP t a two core or a four core CPU and
it runs
literally my network so yeah we just get
a little NW that's
fine lowbudget machine flash PF cense on
it that's fine it's yeah that's the
budget will be fine on this the machines
are going to be about 225 Grand I think
for all so that's a significant amount
uh it is worth spending money to invest
properly in potent you know potential uh
uh for the future as well it's
definitely worth doing correctly yeah
and well the first time and if it's
complicated we can fly we fly link out
fly well flying Linko is not gonna you
know necessarily solve the problems that
that need need to be solved in the
planning stage right you cannot throw
one link key at it and be done you can't
throw one linky at it and be done uh do
you have people to help you set set this
stuff up
too or we the wir and stuff yeah I'm
going I was going to set the machines up
you're going to do them all oh if you
GNA take a long time like a really long
time
probably I mean it shouldn't be that bad
if the it's going to be annoying to
figure out how to set up the anable
script to like flash everything and to
make sure I actually get the base image
right but physically putting the
machines in the racks is not that bad um
that's not bad neither is really wiring
it I do agree the worst thing is going
to
be take me a few days I've I've
personally never used anible but well I
don't I'm not tied to that there's
something
better well yeah anal has playbooks and
I hear great things about it I've just
never used it but ideally you get a
script set up so every machine is
literally like a a clone it makes
everything easier to work with we just
use Prometheus as well to Mon and then
are you still married to Debian have you
thought about switching we're probably
going to switch to a bun
too um I'm assuming still using
containers for everything yes that's
that's happening
still um do you plan on getting more
fancy with your containers you're going
to have to upgrade from everybody gets
the same container right when you log in
you're going to need
like
can't it's literally because we're not
going to do the goal isn't to be time
sharing machines right that's a pain in
the ass and that like just pisses people
off the goal is we're going to have 40
boxes people are going to be allocated
the number of boxes that they need and
that's going to be
that sounds good as long as yeah
technically if you want be more
efficient with stuff you can put slurm
on stuff but then the thing is like you
have to [ __ ] put everything through a
job Q system that pisses everybody off
and makes it harder for everyone and
then you don't have capacity when you
need it and it's like stupid so we're
just going to it's basically just going
to be like people get you know the
number of nodes they need for the amount
of time that they need
them okay um I would I'm trying to think
how to work
this I understand you want you want to
head more towards an assign boxes not Q
jobs I get that I preach into the choir
here I think that's a wonderful system
it works out then you can like verify
capacity way easier I
understand to say
is couple of things that need to be
figured out a under no situation you
should have people be able to escape
container which is that that needs to be
solved we don't really we really well
for you're not going to be able to solve
that we really don't care that much it's
it's use very useful in fact yeah we
don't give people on pseudo on the main
boxes so that they don't [ __ ] with stuff
but it's mainly it's just like we're not
going to have random ass people on here
and if you [ __ ] with my uh if you [ __ ]
with my servers a little bit then you're
getting kicked off and you [ __ ] with my
server is a lot I'm taking you to court
as simple as that yeah I mean no one's I
don't think anyone's going to be [ __ ]
with
them
um okay then I mean you're you're
probably not going to go for user
grouping blah blah blah verifying we
would probably we might do something so
that you can only SSH to your
boxes
um that shouldn't be too hard to figure
out what were you gon to suggest linky
or or say atast
um well that's why I was asking like the
whole Docker container situation and all
that
because
sorry um if that were the case why don't
you just if you're if you're already
saying people are signing paperwork have
an account creation system tonight other
been blogging in under the puffer user
and then you can really limit like this
user has this permission when they open
up it spins up their container versus
like someone
else's oh yeah know that's a that's a
good idea if we can find a way to do it
simply sure but yeah like um here the
thing is people shouldn't be sharing the
boxes really anyway so they shouldn't
have to be managing multiple different
user containers on the same machine
right so here's
a I just imagine a world where I have a
lean key at puffer box and then there's
a simple way to do that I just it's
annoying because then you have to go
into each box you're going to assign
people and add them like add users or
whatever which is kind of
obnoxious no you have groups assigned
you have boxes assigned to groups and
then users assigned to groups and only
users of certain group can like only
if you're a user in a group you can only
use those subset of
boxes if there's a simple way to do it
then sure I also Imagine in a perfect
world where I go okay I was on puffer
box too but now I'm lean key logging
into puffer box 5 and then all the
configurations are essentially the same
but that's also getting like really into
active directory blah blah blah and I'm
not going to sell you on that because
that is
in a hand basket you can set that up
however or whatever uh I think more
pressingly or more more pertinent to the
the operation as as you as you imagine
it Joseph is a One-Stop shoer of view or
a dashboard or something that displays
what is going on on each box in in a
glance and who is assigned to the
boxes a dashboard's easy to do uh or
whether or not they are you know
occupied or or uh you know basic
basically it doesn't have to say who it
is right but but they can be invisible
to people who they're not you know or or
whatever whatever a solution is but a
One-Stop shop for monitoring in that
fashion and for the assignment so you
can see what's available what's going on
at a glance instead of having to I mean
it's pain enough going through the boxes
currently
to determine these things so scale it up
is going to be much much more painful if
you assign multiple boxes to to a team
uh they probably don't want to be going
through that either uh they'll do it but
it's a you know it's quite tedious and
doesn't need to be I don't think the
goal is the goal is that it's just like
yep sign this paper download tail scale
yet you're in exactly it's supposed to
be like the thing is everything with
puffer is is supposed to be the easiest
damn stuff you've ever done that's what
puffer gives you it's the easiest damn
thing you've ever done we take RL which
is this impossible curse thing and
everything including the infrastructure
is the easiest B thing you've ever done
that's the completely agree uh it need
you missed the point where the easier on
the end user the harder on the
management that's that dich okay I deal
with all the [ __ ] anyways well
you're not going to be able to deal with
it if you have you know if you have like
actively 40 different boxes right I mean
it's like it's the thing is yeah 40
boxes if you look at it that way but if
I have like 20 users and I have two
people doing dumb [ __ ] I can tell these
two people to stop doing dumb
[ __ ] sure but then you have you you you
have four users that don't know how to
do X and and five users that have this
problem or that problem you know
uh I'm I think I'm G have more problems
like the more [ __ ] I like put on these
things the more problems I'm probably
going to have like I think we're going
to do basic logging right we're going to
make sure we have clean images we're not
going to do Debian because we had to use
the stupid unstable packages anyways
when I have a bun two I have a bun two
on this machine right here it's been
nice and stable um so we're going to
just learn from the small cluster and
fix a few things
streamline um we're going to get AMD
chip not going to deal with that [ __ ]
and it's going to be like at least
substantially easier than
before can I make a request and just say
can we neuter all can we neuter Ubuntu
of the snap package there are no snap
packages we're not using
snap I agree that's what I'm saying can
we just remove can we minimal we do like
to minimal
install all right without all the
garbage um that's big wins
then back to the basics firewall switch
do you how many boxes if it's more than
48 you're definitely going to need two
switches
um so you said they will have redundant
power or no they have there's a UPS that
can keep them up for a minute while the
generator kicks
on okay it's a big ass it's a big ass
generator that's not just for the boxes
it like it's going to power adjacent
buildings and stuff gotcha so one one
one plug though for each one plug for
plug is going running to power running
to the UPS then yeah which will you know
keep on long enough the for the
generator to kick in
and pretty big
UPS all I am just gonna say this because
you're going to need two switches holy
[ __ ] are they
expensive
what you're going to need
switches or a switch I should say a 48
Port managed gigabit Poe plus switch
with 4 10 gig SFP plus
up um
$659 that's nothing I thought you were
that's fine thought you were gonna say
16,000 you know yeah we don't care
that's fine 650 is [ __ ] nothing like
literally not even you want me to price
out some
brocades like like get get good quality
parts that aren't going to [ __ ] fail
and Grand I'm GNA save PO off but right
don't don't and obviously we don't need
like super Enterprise grad stuff either
right it has to be it has to be you know
above hobby grade yeah we don't need
this [ __ ] that's marked up 10x for no
[ __ ] reason exactly don't don't pay
the Ripoff prices speak we got good
prices I'm pretty happy with the Box
prices as well um they upgraded the
motherboards so we're doing workstation
class motherboards and such so that adds
a little bit but there's still I mean
they're still pretty good it's going to
be about 5 and a half a box um that's
with 509s those are two grand cards
right that's with like I looked at it
and the markup is only I think that the
final markup is going to be like a
thousand is per box it's not bad sounds
about right um L linky this is like this
is like with this is like a house that
young young people young people would
buy like this is the price of a house
so you know hard Hardware to support a
house like Hardware that you want to L
and work corly
Etc I mean it is it is right like in the
schema it's
like a pretty personally but like in the
scheme of things this is a pretty small
amount of hardware for an AI company to
get like we're getting we are getting a
lot more compute than a lot of companies
have uh for a lot less money because
it's RL spec like if you people would
buy like 40 uh like companies would go
buy 40 uh H hundreds and that right
there is 800 Grand not including the
machines right yeah it's extremely it's
extremely efficient I was trying to very
very efficient press upon linky the the
you know the scale of it obviously I
mean this is not crazy right like this
is a lot right now but
uh I like all I got to do is get puffer
to five clients and that's 50k a month
coming in at least so it's like in the
scheme of things it's like it's not
ridiculous out of it I don't even care
about that honestly like in the grand
scheme of things it's not a lot of
machines it's a small business's wor
it's like a small it's yeah it's not
ridiculous highend but machines yeah
okay so yeah linky you know look for
parts appropriate to do that no just get
a lir three switch get I don't I'm not
going to play Parts picker here because
why not I mean 10 gabit one G Parts
picker he doesn't do
networks I'm not paying for it know
you're
not you like my my advice is
firewall layer 3
switch all of those get plugged into
machines at least one line to each
machine is is what it's sounding like
um that'll give you about as much
management as you need it'll give you
the ability to set up your subnets uh
vlans VLAN
tagging
like routing like that's pretty much
Network side what you need all the other
fancy crap is like if and or in but you
already you're getting a pdu
um so I got to look into all this [ __ ]
and see how complicated it is um yeah
and just take one sh it doesn't even
have to be a good box one of the
high-end ones get a [ __ ] box put it in
there call it the management machine and
say Ian if I start if I get that and I
have no idea what the hell I'm doing
like can I get you SSH to the box and
pay you to set the stuff
up yeah okay cool so I like worst case
scenario I'm still covered
right yeah I would need more than likely
need pseudo yeah whatever that'll be
fine that's fine um and then I would
turn the log server into just a
management box which would be a log
server and it has
like
Network like I guess like Network
installed packages so I can actually
like run a quick sweep and go here are
the local IPS of these machines let me
ssh in from the
management um if you're G to be if
you're be using if you're going to be
using it if you're if you're going to
be uh you know an administrator of it it
might be smart to you know I don't even
care if he like takes Pudo away from me
after like I don't pick the right it
might be smart to pick the right parts
right to make it proper so that you fix
see look I'm going to look at it and if
I'm like I don't know what I'm doing
I'll yeah I'll
just it will I'll just do yeah I'll uh
just whatever I'll advise as much as I
can my my degree of concern is high
still as long as you can get so far as a
VPN with me on it yeah everything
connected like you plug the firewall in
that will be your router you get a DHCP
server running on that they do it
automatically um and then connect that
to the switch and then the switch to
every other machine in there and you can
just I can VPN into the network I can I
can manage that at least so it's like if
I don't know what I'm doing we're cover
it's
fine I can even go through and set up
like static IPS within your local
network that way you can always expect
these boxes to be on like I don't know
if we really static I I think tail scale
if we just use tail scale for it we're
kind of covered with that yeah it gives
you like a pay for user not for box so
it's like
whatever here's what I'm trying to
accomplish though tail scale if the box
is hung in the tail scale service on
that box died can I still access it
locally through VPN and if that's the
case really lovely if box 28 was in 1921
1681 128 that's all that's
fair well I if the box is hung it would
be nice to figure out a way to
remotely reboot the damn things if
they're like hard crap is a man
mandatory that's the screwy it must be
mandatory there are scuffy ways to fix
that and then there are expensive ways
to fix that so expensive would be
the an actual power outlet like worst
case scenario all machines are set
to when AC power is detected to turn on
and then you could just toggle the
actual power to the machine the scuffy
way
is installing something to hijack the
button
press you just short short the two pins
for a moment and it turns on a relay can
do the job but then you're doing that
scuffy work on every and
yeah the scuffi one is the fit like the
box that presses the
button I mean a a p a pdu would
be would be
wise thing you have to it's depends you
have to [ __ ] do that on every damn
box well you can every box is if every
box is set up to actually turn on when
AC power is detected I believe is
generally what Dell names the option
yeah these are standard Outlets though
so like we'd have to
have I don't
know yeah you can have a surge protector
between it that allows you to say the
surge protector has 10 plugs on it then
you could just say plug
one maybe
already already it's massively
Jank yeah that exists and is a solution
for racks by the
way that's some it can work but yeah a
pdu a pdu would be smart and a network
connected pdu of
course yeah the remote restart I can't
really help because that's
like I've not had to do I have server
grade like it needs to
be on a power distribution unit so that
you can manage the
power yeah but what happens is you go
look at the server grade ones and you
see the what they charge just for the
putting the freaking server Factor no
it's yeah this are you talking the giant
rack batteries just go like oh look we
can go H why does this one start $400
more I'm sure that it won't go up way
more than $400 more when I click on it
right uh let's see we can
do pro
RS where is this
thing
figure oh let's see yes this is a server
unit and then we do
oh look just the rails okay then we do
oh they got these on the website already
that's
cool oh it doesn't even have a 4090
option isn't that
weird and here's the kicker probably
doesn't fit in the [ __ ] server
wack so we're at
3700 for a garbage machine with a 47
unit
this is here's the kicker is that pretty
much the desktop just dropped into a
server exactly and we're at
that so we're at 5,000 with a garbage
this is actually not as bad as I thought
it would be to be fair but I don't think
this thing fits I don't think this thing
fits the
but this is still a workstation
motherboard isn't
it yeah that's what I'm saying so that
is doesn't even have the freaking featur
D it's not even going to network
boot correct well no I mean desktops can
Network boot like anything can Network
boot when they're
crashed oh that well yeah that's yeah we
I don't like there's not really a point
there's really not a point of putting
them in this form factor is
there outside of just static airf flow
and and managing no point in putting
into that form factor all this all this
does is makes it harder to sell in a few
years I yeah I would not put them in
those like you can you the desktops you
can sell those at half price in like two
to three
years yeah saw space isn't an issue
which it probably isn't it sounds
like I'm still waiting for you to retire
one of the Intel
boxes yeah send those over what the [ __ ]
is this
like it'll it'll yeah starting at
$28,000 yeah don't tiny is I think 25
Grand I mean it better it better better
be really really really good for for
that I I think you just buy a tiny box
yeah there
is their desktops are pretty damn good
though yeah you just do uh
do
m50x you
oops they do have a air cooler so I
don't know what this is on
yeah do you at least save some money
that way
what going from water cooled the air
cooled H maybe a
little
4800 and let's see so there's a few
other things on
this uh but I'm forgetting a couple
things cuz it was higher than this oh
yeah it's the uh workstation motherboard
board goes up a
little yeah that Windows trash out of
here me do what is it
this yeah this
thing got their 490s
quoted they actually don't even
have ever going to
see I got a quote at the very least I
got to pay for it on Monday so we res
it
yeah oh yeah does Razer have their
laptops out
yet I can check real quick
see I need a new La I have not like my
laptop is
dying my laptop is
dying it's like gig H nope they don't
have his
yet so I keep checking
back whenever uh these are
out I I don't even think they have
laptops at the moment
$4,000 for a
laptop shouldn't be
4,000 [ __ ] that you you could buy cars
for
$4,000 this one is what this
2300 this is 2300 for uh laptop a 16inch
470 Quad HD 240
Herz um so like I like the thing is
Razor actually gotten good with their
pricing you can't really find this for a
better price you actually can't find
this anywhere you can't find anything
comparable
cheaper another razor laptop uh got a
4090 an i
94900 where do you see
I'm on
Amazon those aren't out I don't know how
those are there 4090 yeah those aren't
like oh 4090 yeah okay yeah not 5090 but
it's also it is a for but it's not a k
so it's Up For Debate if chips or flim I
probably won't go I'm not going to get a
4090 laptop I'm probably going to get
like a 4070 or something that won't be
on literal fire
yeah and to be fair I don't need a
$4,000
laptop also probably a good call to
ditch
Intel yeah we're proba we're GNA do AMD
from
now don't give
me goad Intel's been struggling dude
they screwed us over so bad with our
cluster I got to do this micro Cod
updates maybe tomorrow I also have to I
also have to design my gym tomorrow
though so
we'll see the facility contains two
things the facility contains servers and
the facility contains a
gy are you going to live there
y Dam let me tell you when you find a
girl and bring her
over when you find a girl over nobody's
going to be able to hear anything coming
from inside that that place that's the I
mean hey that's the freaking litmus test
okay
you don't you don't like you don't like
the server wareh the server gym
Warehouse [ __ ]
off I heard you like like noise to go to
sleep
too I'll be right back n that stuff's
like way on the other side it's like way
on the far wall it'll be
fine what happened with uh Intel in the
cluster curious they shipped two
consecutive generations of broken ships
that just s
fault
oh that sounds bad yes yes it is very
bad to ship two generations of
consecutive broken
ships I'm a little confused
why this thing is so damn confident
I guess it's because I'm penalizing it
from
huh I might have to look at that there
might have to be a better Suite of
synthetic benchmarks
we'll see just annoying because carbs is
actually not that fast to run it takes a
few seconds for
start I'm trying to think if I shouldn't
be
penalizing there's a local Improvement
term and then there's a global
Improvement
term they're both at the moment they're
conservative meaning that they're
subtracting their uncertainty from their
prediction but maybe I should only be
penalizing uncertainty on the global
scale which would then allow it a little
bit more freedom to explore on the lower
end cuz it's like it's too scared to
explore
or it's like too scared to explore
certain hyper
amazing we'll see what this did you ever
see that uh like hyper parameter fral GI
and let me see if I can find it the PB
BT or
something
it's it always made me a little bit
afraid of hyper
like well trying to understand hyper
parameters um oh I think I I think I
know it's yeah the weird thing where
it's like so
can put it in uh in general if you want
to see
it it's like there's a pretty clear
boundary at like the little the macro
scale of like but then if you zoom in on
the hyper parameters it's just sort of
like an
infinitely weird like it's like a
fractal right
funny we just Tred to hyper parameter go
bar yeah
oh although you know I guess it's
important to know that what they're
zooming on on there is like a boundary
right it's so maybe you don't you know
you hopefully you're not like exactly in
a boundary between not working and
working
um I think I'm going to probably cue One
new
new one on this then go to sleep at
tomorrow I might do the micro code at
least tomorrow we'll see a layout the
gym order that
equipment set up the payment
for prototype machine and a couple other
small things the goal for next week so
there going to be some academic collabs
there's some client work and then I I
really want this hyper parameter thing
to be like the first major science side
thing that we get working
solidly
um the goal is that when you launch
experiments right when you launch a
hyper parameter sweep you should be
pretty damn confident that it's found
your best hyper parameters like you
should be confident that the issue is
not hyper parameters after running a
sweep so you know whatever result you
get you're getting the best the best
hyper parameters you can find that's the
best version that you're getting with
the current algorithm architecture
Etc because right now there's this huge
amount of sensitivity the hyper
parameters and like it almost doesn't
matter what your architectural algorithm
are because you still have no idea
whether it's good or not because of the
stupid hyper parameter
sensitivity yeah that that definitely
makes a lot of
sense that's I think this is like the
biggest bang for your buck first problem
to look at it's kind of a hard
problem and I I like I wish that I like
one of the baselines would be better
like I looked at Asha but it's
really it can't be as good as it's shown
in the paper because it just can't
fundamentally based on what it is um so
I think that just
like I think a lot of these hyperr
baselines are just weaker than they
should be
because they're just not tuned correctly
I don't know what to say like they they
have weird decisions and they're not set
up correctly um yeah it's kind of weird
that like outperforms hebo and stuff but
like I guess for RL they're like they
kind of did some additional
considerations on hebo but then there's
still some like some bugs and errors and
stuff I know when you see 2,000 lines of
code that wether should be 700 you kind
of know some stuff's going to be dranky
and
broken so
I probably should just make a better
synthetic test and get better local
logging for them
um and then figure out if I can speed up
carbs because it just takes too long to
run the damn thing on a test like really
you want like if you to run random
search it runs instantly and you just
get your experiment feedback
instantly
um
yeah random search is not a terrible
Baseline actually actually with the way
that we've implemented it now
so we will
see how's this
maybe well yeah I mean looking at it
it's just it's scared to do anything
I I can just
like mess with
the I can just like mess with the scal
of
stuff and try again
pong is a decent one cuz pong probably
it only takes like an hour to
run and it's like a real like it's a
real environment when it takes like an
hour to
oh yeah no we're good this is on the
same
box and I'm
backen ke to go to
bed all
Gooding
on working on working you're goingon to
need uh access control as well Joseph by
the way tail
skill Access Control physical Access
Control what do you mean
what what do I mean what do I mean any
any any data
center has rules and access controls so
that no incorrect people can be anywhere
so buy a
shotgun no no I mean like a physical
like cage with a lock on it yeah it's
called his house yeah
exactly yeah okay a lock he already said
he was he already said who's going to be
living there
yeah it's a it's it's like it's a
warehouse with a gym and a and a data
center it
basically I
see it has room for like a small office
a pretty sizable gym a data center a
bedroom and a
shower
cool this a nice Warehouse
good yeah it sounds great if you ever
need anything just let me know you'll
plan a tri for me to come
on
um I mean this has been a crazy busy
week I did I got GPU drive from 35k up
to 250k and got the basic hyper Prem
sweep stuff had a chat with them maybe
tomorrow I did an initial integration of
um intersection Zoo which is this
traffic control end for MIT we'll see
how they like that uh I got to go back
and forth with them that took quite a
bit of work I did Isaac gym integration
for a client that uh that seems to be
working
decently I got uh this a lot of hyper
parameter sweet stuff done in puffer
that's what I've been doing on science
side so far and I reviewed several
thousand lines of code from
contributors out of
curiosity sorry
continue yeah um do you do like contract
integration yeah it's like it's right on
the website
right well no I mean like so if let's
say I had a company and I was like ah
cool puffer lib up and coming great
let's let's give this a world it seems
like a perfect fit can they hire you as
like contract to rework it for their
purposes and basically basically the
farther you take us away from the agenda
of what we're doing with puffer the more
we
charge so yeah the base service package
is for you have you want to use puffer
lib you're going to need a few things of
integration and you need us to like rep
prioritize a couple features from 6
months from now up to next week that's
like the type of stuff the base package
is for right extended support
reprioritization of features a little
bit of
integration um know if you have
something that's like substantially
farther away from that that's like you
know farther from what we would be doing
anyways we still help with it but you
know we're going to charge cuz we're not
getting the code back to puffer lib
right CU that's like a lot of the
benefit is we continue to build out
puffer so they the compass to be higher
so the base like the base packages from
puffer are 10K for support and all the
stuff that I do and then it goes up from
there what are your thoughts on and I'm
this
is purely hypotheticals because I don't
I'm I'm just asking to
ask
um if you had to rework some of puffer
lib to meet a company's agenda and they
had agreed on whatever price both of you
deemed
fit at what point like do you draw a
line and say anything past this point
is technically the company's property
and it's proprietary like how do you
handle those Niche the niche situations
to say that like my Project's open
source and anybody can use their the
code how they deem fit but now you're
hired under a company yeah you own you
own integration stuff right it's just
the the general stuff that benefits
puffer lip right it's going to stay open
source and the thing is like as a client
you want it to be open source because it
gets tested against all of the other
stuff in puffer lip and maintained and
tested by all the people that use puffer
lips it's going to be more stable you
don't have to deal with it and it gets
tested against all our environments and
whatnot right so really the only thing
that uh clients should even want is the
bindings and Integrations for their
specific stuff which aren't useful to
puffer Li so sure you can keep those but
again it's like the more work that we
have to spend our time doing on that
side the more the base price is going to
go up thus far most of what we're doing
for clients is pretty darn close to what
we want to do anyways with puffer just
you know reprioritized in time frame and
we're mostly looking for clients to do
that at the moment um bigger contracts
will come later but the thing is like by
the time we get to later right puffer is
going to be larger and we'll probably
just cover a lot of the things that
people are going to want anyways like by
the time we have really good hyper cram
sweeps and we fixed up the algorithms
and stuff it's just more problems that
are going to be easier to get
working yeah yeah stop sing Z
files next time somebody sends a zip
file I'm sending him a zip bomb
back yeah
you zip bomb me I I'm surprised he used
zip uh just it's 40 m okay I'm right by
the box I can go press the button why is
it 40 me why is it 40
megabytes this looks maybe a little
better we'll see
how I am I've got a goal in mind Joe
how complex is naral
MMO it's only one of the most complex RL
environments out there that's not that's
not what I'm
asking
um with like how many tiers of armors do
you have multiple attack types what have
you played it kind fun damn
say say say you've never say you've
never
touched 3 without saying you've never
touched an3 you just uh you left control
is a toggle so you can you can run
around right and let's see if I find a
level one to fight like he's actually
Ming okay so now I found I got a shovel
I can equip the shovel get away from me
stop follow me I'm not interested in you
sir let's see we're going to go get some
some
armors let's equip this it's on the
[ __ ] website yeah isn't it awesome it
run where have you been like yeah not
here obviously how often have I been
posting in Discord
still I thought you were like I
mean I mean I read most of the things
right so like it's kind of hard though
like you got to be uh you got to be kind
of smart with stuff stuff cuz if you run
into a high level too early you're kind
of just dead instantly and like this 24
will one shot me from range the higher
level one to
bows this guy's going to [ __ ] me up
yeah there you see okay so but like yeah
there's like I think it's like level 20
or 30 I forget what I said it to um
there's like I think five tiers of armor
here if I just put control back
on um how many do you have like
like you can see that there are all
sorts of different
items all sorts of different enemies um
there's a bow there's a sword there's
kind of some tech with both of them that
you can use to gain advantages if you're
clever um there's healing items there
there are like these elemental gems that
give you like Pokemon super effective
not very effective stuff
um well I remember when you
were a lot of Stu what I was what I was
asking specifically is how complex in
the sense of like you already answered
one of my questions how many tiers of
armor is five do you have any skills
outside of combat or is it just all like
Gathering base uh you level up for
defeating a foe of equal or greater
level than uh to yourself and then you
level up your harvesting ability uh like
you get a certain number of harvests in
each team tier like like I think it's
like the first it's like eight levels
per tier or
whatever okay so this policy it's kind
of like probably there's more hyperr
stuff to be done but like this policy is
decent but this policy is played I
think, 1500 years of neural Mo
rate okay it's 75 billion steps it
stopped improving after 75 billion steps
um yeah but 1500 years of nur3
so I was asking because what I've been
doing is making what I call 2D top down
RuneScape via
terminal so everything's terminal
rendered um and I'm trying to make it as
complex as RuneScape minus
questing yeah runescape's very [ __ ]
Lex I will say a former top 1%
player I've already got so I've got all
combat skills working unique
area unique attack areas based off of
like what style you're using it's weapon
based honestly so like there is more
variety that's going to come I do have
wood cutting in mining already figured
out uh with currently eight tiers of
trees and
ores um more to come goes it's very
[ __ ] hard to like get these things
working in balc for RL it's that's a
good thing to be doing
though I'm making it
massive granted I have been riding it as
a server and client but I'm riding the
environment n 3 runs at 1.9 about 1.9
million steps per second on One
Core yeah I a do not expect mine to run
anywhere near that
fast yeah I kind of like this was I kind
of wrote this environment as like a big
[ __ ] you to like all of RL environment
Dev to say you can just make
ridiculously complicated things very
fast my camera's frozen ridiculous
position isn't it now why did nobody
tell me it's been like that for minute
there why did nobody [ __ ] tell me
that
[ __ ] but
happy I have no hopes mine's gonna run
anywhere near that fast but I did write
it so the environment is using the
gymnasium API just so it can be like
integrated buffer native API faster
correct
so and then I'll look at
like
sioning a good portion of what I it's
easy it's honestly just easier just go
straight to see I know I know you've
already
said like if you look at the code for
this this is 2,800 lines of
C yeah but you're not including rib in
that
includes the [ __ ] raid client not the
raid
Source it's like that's like that's such
an arbitrary uh yeah I'm not including
the source for the sea language either I
know I know have you done any simpler
environments it might be that an MMO is
uh I made this one like oh I I was um
talking uh is it linky Le yeah yeah lean
it might be if this you done any other
environments what do you mean have I
done like have I read new programmer
must go through the trial by fire of
attempting to write an entire MMO and
getting absolutely destroyed like I
don't what you're talking about because
it is functional right now items
entities
PVP like all combat is solved I have two
like I would say it's near complete
there's
just okay can I pull it we can play yeah
it's playable are you going to host the
server I mean I have to turn it on
yeah I I I could you got the domain make
make yeah I do have I do have a sick
TLD um yeah yeah no it's playable
there's just not variety there yet I do
like that's literally what I'm working
on
um so I'm not really concerned with that
I have made other environments not to
completion though and a lot of what I've
done in this one was based off of a
hide-and seek that I
abandoned a while
ago I remember that you should just
start W these things and see linky it's
like it's way easier than you'd think
he's uh he's uh he's already faked
himself out
so what do you mean if you actually look
at the code and see it's like it's
really pretty damn simple and it's so
it's just so nice to just have
everything be fast and just compile
instantly and just test instantly it's
so nice convince yourself that it's hard
and it's not that hard yeah it's not
really that hard honestly I understand
that having written Java Python and Java
is [ __ ] okay Java is like torture
okay python is fine if you don't get
fancy but everybody gets
fancy I kind of fancy I've been
like trying new things and learning but
I don't like about things I've been
using a lot of static methods
recently um fancy for what
reason
none fancy
um yeah it's it's honestly I could write
it in and I have to
like learn a whole bunch of make that I
just don't care to right now that's
thank
you is this too ambitious trying to
solve this and am I like just screwing
myself over doing this 10 million frames
not trying to get anything is it too
ambitious okay so your your test your
test environment well I don't the thing
is I actually don't know how many steps
you can solve this environment I know
you can solve it in 20 with optimized
hyper
parameters right you have to pick a
might just be that 10 is too low to
really get any
progress I could probably do a what I
should do is I should do a random sweep
at 10 just to see like what you
get right or you can compare to Old
carbs I don't think it'll work there
either I am going
to
screenshot Joseph's face in this picture
you posted bet and then change all the
puffer box puffer fishes in the terminal
to Jay's face yeah it's pretty good
picture though [ __ ]
off it's a good
picture we could animate it to puff up
as well that would be
good put a watermark why can't you take
the picture of me why can't I get the
picture of me when the camera was frozen
like a month ago when I was like 190 PBS
with the same body fat and [ __ ]
jacked okay you look fine I mean no no
one no no one could no one could tell
you know that's a people don't know
that's like a 6xl shirt you have on
I think they're all mediums
actually yeah the basil shirt's
definitely a medium that Polo it's
definitely Med
mediums I don't like him super
loose we call those
mediums okay I don't like the way that
the sweep is going so I think I'm going
to
do yeah it's not going yeah I think
we're going to just do we're going to do
2 E7 then we're go like this and then
this should actually freaking learn
something and if this doesn't learn
something then we'll be we'll start to
get
concerned we'll compare not loading I'm
not restarting my browser it's not
loading hurts my
soul I mean this is starting to do
something well there may be a trend yeah
hopefully that's a trend I think that
the I think some of the pams are too um
are too
conservative that could like they get
kind of
stuck we'll
see okay it's time for me to go to sleep
um I
been this has been what 14 15 hour
day streamed for 15 hours today I think
I
did yeah the last the last couple have
kind of just been chilling and checking
the experiments but
um we pretty much just did a full
algorithm
today like this amount of changes to
carbs this is like a full new algorithm
and I bet now I think it's going to be
pretty good and we're probably just
going to have to tweak like some ranges
on stuff maybe there'll be like one
small tweak I don't know about making
the
local the local bound conservative in
the algorithm so there might be a couple
small things to a blate there but I
think that we'll get something good out
of
this I think we should get something
good out of
this agree it should not be that hard as
well to compare
like we can get baselines for these
things pretty easily like for instance I
could just do 40 million steps right 40
million steps is like a minute and a
half or something and I can do pong I
can just do random surf that and that'll
be like a
baseline there's so much stuff I can do
with this
I think we still have a couple folks
somehow on
YouTube all right
so I'm I'm going to get off here so for
folks on uh YouTube all this stuff is
free and open source it's on
puff. I will be streaming ridiculous Dev
hours for the foreseeable future so you
can find me here star the repo on dis uh
start the repo on GitHub please it
really helps me out it's free doesn't
cost
anything join the Discord where I guess
the banner is broken but there are 900
people in here you can join and start
doing some cool RL stuff and you can
follow me on X where I post pretty much
just fre reinforcement learning content
including guides and there's some custom
articles you can only find there as
well other than that I will
be I don't know if I'll be streaming
tomorrow definitely be back on Monday if
I do any on this I'll stream it but uh
I'm probably going to be laying out gy
and then maybe doing micro code updates
we'll see if there's any time for
anything else uh yeah if you guys if you
guys in the Discord here if you have
anything for me to review or whatever
tomor I can probably still do that we'll
see I don't get to do my long run
tomorrow because freaking stupid
pneumonia uh I get I think I get to
start running a little bit again on
Monday we'll
see and it was though not